This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So earlier this month, we wrapped up the 99% of visible Kickstarter fundraising campaign. And it was amazing. We had 5,661 backers and raised over $170,000. Oh my, that was not what I was expecting. So the huge show of support for the program made news around the world. It was the highest earning journalism project in Kickstarter history. So we're gearing up for season three. And it won't be long. It's going to be in September, so just a few weeks, a couple weeks.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。本月初，我们结束了《99%隐形》的Kickstarter筹款活动。结果令人惊叹。我们有5661名支持者，筹集了超过17万美元。天哪，这完全超出了我的预期。节目获得如此巨大的支持，引起了全球媒体的关注。这是Kickstarter历史上筹款额最高的媒体项目。我们正在为第三季做准备，很快就会到来。就在九月，再过几周，几周而已。
But I've got a few thousand envelopes to stuff, and we've got to get Sam unpacked and get everything sort of working in order and other work together. And rather than doing repeats or just making you wait for the new season, I'm gonna present stories from producers that I love, but who didn't actually produce these stories from 99% invisible, but when you hear them, I'm pretty sure you're gonna figure out why I thought
但我还有几千个信封要装，我们得把萨姆的东西拆包，把一切整理好，把工作协调好。与其重播旧节目或让你们干等新一季，我打算介绍一些我喜欢的制作人制作的故事。虽然这些故事并非出自《99%隐形》，但当你听的时候，我相信你会明白为什么我觉得
they'd be perfect for the show in terms of the subjects they cover and why I thought you'd love them too. Our first short story, very, very short stories from Ireland. It's a series called Language Bites. Language Bites. Story. Door is opening. Have you ever wondered why a level or floor on a building is called a story?
它们非常适合这个节目，无论是从它们涵盖的主题来看，还是从我为什么认为你们也会喜欢它们来看。我们的第一个短篇故事，来自爱尔兰的非常非常短的故事。这是一个名为《语言咬文嚼字》（Language Bites）的系列。语言咬文嚼字。故事。门开了。你有没有想过，为什么建筑物的一层楼被称为“故事”（story）？
Door is closing. That's a word we associate with a level or floor and a building is called a story? Dorns clothing! That's a word we associate with a narrative or tale. And actually, it's not far off the origin of the word we associate with architecture. And its use takes us back to the 14th century. Where are we going? The word story comes from the ancient Greek word, Historia, meaning account of events. In the 1300s, architects are in the habit of decorating buildings with stained glass
门关上了。那是我们与叙事或传说联系在一起的词，而建筑物的一层楼却被称为“故事”？门关上了！那是我们与叙事或传说联系在一起的词。实际上，这与我们现在与建筑相关的词的起源相差不远。它的使用可以追溯到14世纪。我们要去哪儿？“Story”一词源于古希腊语“Historia”，意为事件的记录。在1300年代，建筑师习惯用彩色玻璃装饰建筑物，
and stone carvings or sculptures. These carvings were on the outside of the building, and they depicted actual stories. Some of them recounted ancient myths and legends. And on churches and cathedrals, they often depicted Bible stories. So you can see where this is going. The higher the building, the more stories it had. And eventually, the word story was used to refer to an entire floor or level. First story.
以及石雕或雕塑。这些雕刻在建筑物外部，描绘了真实的故事。其中一些讲述了古代神话和传说。在教堂和大教堂上，它们经常描绘圣经故事。所以你可以看出这是怎么回事了。建筑物越高，它包含的“故事”就越多。最终，“story”一词被用来指代整个楼层或水平面。第一层（First story）。
Language Bites is produced by Collette Cancella, sound designed by Lockwood Hart. The series was produced for and first broadcast on RTE Choice in Ireland. Our next short piece is from Nate Tomeo in Memory Palace. Nate produced episode number 27 of 9-Nen of Invisible Long ago, but his connection with the show does not end there. Nate was one of the first people I called when I started Night Epsen of Invisible because essentially, I wanted to do stories like he was doing on the subject of history, but I wanted to do them about architecture and design.
《语言咬文嚼字》由科莱特·坎塞拉制作，洛克伍德·哈特负责声音设计。该系列是为爱尔兰RTE Choice电台制作并首次播出的。我们的下一个短片来自《记忆宫殿》（Memory Palace）的内特·托梅奥。内特制作了《99%隐形》的第27集，那是很久以前的事了，但他与本节目的联系并未就此结束。当我开始制作《99%隐形》时，内特是我联系的第一批人之一，因为本质上，我想做他那种关于历史主题的故事，但我希望它们是关于建筑和设计的。
So if you're already familiar with Night Epsen of Invisible, you'll hear the shared DNA in our progenitor, The Memory palace. This story is called Damn. This is the memory palace, I'm Nate DeMail. In 1931, at the height of the depression, people began hearing that there were going to be jobs in Nevada. They needed men there to build an enormous dam that would be named after a president Herbert Hoover. 5,000 men, former commodities traders, former ops' traditions, packed up their families and drove to the desert. Some of them leaving behind the plywood and scrap metal shanty towns that were also named after Herbert Hoover. When they got there, they found that there were jobs,
所以，如果你已经熟悉《99%隐形》，你会听到我们祖师爷《记忆宫殿》中共享的基因。这个故事叫《大坝》。这是《记忆宫殿》，我是内特·德梅奥。1931年，在大萧条最严重的时期，人们开始听说内华达州会有工作机会。他们需要人在那里建造一座巨大的大坝，这座大坝将以赫伯特·胡佛总统的名字命名。5000名男子，前商品交易员、前歌剧演员，收拾行囊带着家人开车前往沙漠。有些人留下了以赫伯特·胡佛命名的胶合板和废金属棚户区。当他们到达那里时，他们发现确实有工作，
but that the houses in schools and movie theaters that were supposed to be there hadn't been built yet. So they hammered some posts into the ground, and strung up some sheets that could keep the desert sought off their kids and their wives, and they went to work. 96 of those men died, when the harnesses that fastened them to the canyon wall, 800 feet in the air snapped. When the hearts of 50-year-old men who were used to selling women's hosiery were teaching geometry.
但本应在那里的房屋、学校和电影院还没建好。于是，他们把一些柱子钉进地里，挂上床单，为他们的孩子和妻子遮挡沙漠的尘土，然后就开始工作了。其中96人死亡，当他们系在800英尺高空峡谷壁上的安全带断裂时。当那些习惯于卖女式长袜或教几何学的50岁男人的心脏停止跳动时。
When their hearts gave out after working 10-hour shifts in 130-degree heat, chipping a mile-long tunnel beneath a desert inch by inch. When others fell into wet concrete, concrete had to be pulled out, not before they died, then before the concrete set, they became a permanent part of the large public works project. But not long after they finished the dam, orange grows, and al-Falfa fields, and baseball diamonds, and whole cities grew in the desert. There's a monument at Hoover Dam. There are these two enormous bronze angels that are supposed to embody the spirit of the
当他们在130度的高温下工作10小时，在沙漠下一点一点凿出长达一英里的隧道，心脏不堪重负时。当其他人掉进湿混凝土中，混凝土必须被挖出来，在他们死后、混凝土凝固前，他们成为了大型公共工程项目的一部分。但在他们完成大坝后不久，橙树林、苜蓿田、棒球场和整座城市在沙漠中拔地而起。胡佛大坝有一个纪念碑。那里有两尊巨大的青铜天使，旨在体现
men who designed and built the dam, an American progress or whatever. But my favorite part of the monument, my favorite thing about the whole dam dam, is actually at the angel's feet. There's an Art Deco Astronomical chart there, done in is actually the angel's feet. There's an art deco-astronomical chart there done in Tarazo. And it's lovely. And there's some text there that tells you that on September 20th, 1935, President Franklin Delano Roosevelt dedicated the damn. The text goes on to explain that the chart on the ground shows the precise alignment of
设计和建造大坝的人们的精神，美国进步之类的。但我最喜欢纪念碑的部分，我关于整个大坝最喜欢的事情，其实是在天使的脚下。那里有一张装饰艺术风格的天文图，是用磨石子（Terrazzo）做的。它很美。上面有一些文字告诉你，1935年9月20日，富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福总统为大坝揭幕。文字继续解释说，地上的图表显示了精确的对齐方式，
the heavens and exactly 856 went FDR's book. The same moment that a flagpole that stands between the two angels was aimed straight at the heart of the sun. Because they were sure we would care. There's a separate section in the chart that supposedly depicts the precise astronomical location of an Egyptian pyramid when it was aligned Hoover Dam flagpole style with the yonder star that the frankincense toning wise men followed to get to the baby Jesus thereby ushering in the christian era.
即天体在罗斯福总统演讲时的位置。就在那一刻，两尊天使之间的一根旗杆直指太阳的心脏。因为他们确信我们会关心。图表中有一个单独的部分，据称描绘了埃及金字塔在与胡佛大坝旗杆风格对齐时的精确天文位置，指向了东方智者跟随去寻找圣婴耶稣的那颗星星，从而开启了基督教时代。
It loves us because it means that so convinced were the makers of the Hoover Dam that what these men had just built was so world historic, so new epic usheringly awesome that a plaque wouldn't suffice. So they designed this chart, working with astronomers at the Naval Observatory at the Smithsonian. So thousands of years from now, even in an apparently post-English world, when the text right there next to the chart would somehow have been rendered useless. People, or perhaps aliens, could know. They'd be able to do the math and figure out the exact moment when FDR had a day clarin' as calendar to say a few words at the Hoover Dam.
它之所以可爱，是因为这意味着胡佛大坝的建造者们如此确信这些人刚刚建造的东西是如此具有世界历史意义，如此具有史诗般的震撼力，以至于一块牌匾都不足以表达。所以他们设计了这个图表，与史密森尼学会海军天文台的天文学家合作。这样几千年后，即使在一个显然是后英语的世界里，当图表旁边的文字以某种方式变得毫无用处时，人们，或者可能是外星人，也能知道。他们将能够进行计算，并找出罗斯福总统在胡佛大坝发表讲话的确切时刻。
Now the 35th largest hydroelectric plane in the world. And according to the state's tours and website, the ninth best thing to do in Nevada. Number 10 is golf. So that's the special 99% of visible for this week. Season 3 starts very, very soon, but I thought there would be more fun than playing a repeat or waiting a month for a new episode. We have 40 new episodes, a video episode, a new website, it's all coming this season on 99% of its book. If you haven't done it already or this the first
现在它是世界上第35大水电站。根据该州的旅游网站，它是内华达州第10大值得做的事情。第10名是打高尔夫球。这就是本周特别的《99%隐形》。第三季很快就会开始，但我认为这比播放重播或等一个月看新剧集更有趣。我们有40集新剧集、一集视频、一个新网站，这一切都将在《99%隐形》这一季中呈现。如果你还没有这样做，或者这是你第一次
time you're hearing the show, go download the 60-something previous episodes, my name's an invisible that are actually produced by me. They're all short, they're evergreen meaning that they're as timely now as they were when I made them. And they're all good, they're pretty good. As a body of work, I'm quite I made them. And they're all good. They're pretty good. As a body of work, I'm quite proud of them. It's not better than others, but it's a, you know, it has a whole, a whole worth of time. So check them out.
听到这个节目，去下载之前由我制作的60多集《99%隐形》。它们都很短，而且是“常青”的，意味着它们现在和当初制作时一样及时。它们都很好，相当不错。作为一系列作品，我非常为它们感到自豪。有些并不比其他的更好，但它，你知道，它拥有完整的时间价值。所以去看看吧。
We're going to have links to language bites and the memory palace on our website at 99% of visible.org. This program is a project of KALW, 91.7, local public radio in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show like the show and interact with me on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but you can always catch up with us online at 99personinvisible.org. Radio Tepio.
我们将在我们的网站 99percentinvisible.org 上提供《语言咬文嚼字》和《记忆宫殿》的链接。本节目是旧金山当地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7 和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目、点赞并与我互动。我在 Twitter 上叫 Roman Mars，但你总是可以在 99percentinvisible.org 在线收听我们的节目。Radio Tepio。
From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。